welcome to this video playing go from
from Russia frequent opponent a very bad
score is one of those notorious time
players playing every position on time
so I try to to play quickly now have a
position from the fodor's defense and
pretty solid solid set up for both sides
yeah maybe maybe I should have played a
4 at some point I go nite b3 now he will
play em play a form ok don't don't want
I would be too I want to protect him
yeah that's not the position type I have
huge experience on let's seem a bit
inconvenient maybe night a for though
intending to get something to be six
I don't know I really don't don't know
how to play that after the Queen trade
that's maybe also might be too to see
for at some point well if you just not
trade I might have something like c3 the
queen is does not have many squares he's
allowing it okay so we'll see three
Queen a 3a this is really what you want
to do an interesting okay
let's see if I can trap it probably not
with night see to add the moment is also
threatening to take the bishop
I doubt that I can allow him to take and
I don't really see how I can trap the
Queen rook a one maybe maybe look a one
was a possibility but he can probably
take play d 5 or something difficult
position I don't want to spend overly
much time as mentioned he will play
everything on time until you will easily
just extrude everything down to rook
against Luke that happen to win it so
beam and try to be quick em yeah night
be 69 f 50 moves like a Knight b6 first
can take night f5 as this I adds at
least interesting let's say let's do
this and not over over think here
spending too much time it takes I'll
take the age 59 and t6 is at actor
not around threatening the six but you
can play up the aid I'm not threatening
made on g7 now because the night is on
h5 ok give this check here check
96 vs kabuki five in the position
let's let's try to open up at the same
want to get the bishop in the game like
takes Bishop takes getting some pressure
on f7 on rookie 5 i have also Queen f6
it's quite quite annoying the screen and
I keep some edge on the clock I want to
activate this bishop
and does he have some sort of Perpetual
here no would be five I take the rukon
CN
if I take his rookie 55 but Queen d7
smooth too big of a problem
check mmm hot flame quindi age may be
attacking d6
can i play play this phone a text
somehow all right okay it's not it's
really not necessary at all just um just
the end game is perfectly fine I wanted
I schedule gate hmm this I overlooked
okay check time warning
Giles was not not the best possible way
to play it definitely not I'm still fine
but I had had ways tube to play this
much better definitely want to get on f7
name check check check black for fits on
time yeah I like that again ok how about
I already spotted a bit around here I
should win wouldn't win much clearer but
I always kept some match but it should
have been clearer already so around here
Queen f6 mmm yeah Queen f6 is just
stronger of course keeping all the
pressure on that's a plus 5 almost by
the cop John came I mean this
transformation to the endgame should
also win but I i made one mistake here I
really overlooked that he has to sue k7
idea Jax thinks a bit bit tricky
it's always like plus 1.7 1.6 but it it
could have been could have been over a
long time long time ago it was very
tricky this opening and I wonder if I
could have done better if we look here
plate 320 and then I 194 which is
debatable i don't know if this is really
good but he went night h5 c3 creamy
three the compass on on plus to point
something so there is some way to
probably win the CM and i'll probably if
the compass on plus 2 there is a way
Bishop g5 not here but 2g fire
interesting and it's not clear what this
is threatening may be really nice see to
where if we play a zero move yeah like
this Quincy tune cartoon her too hard to
an avid egged it's pretty clear that the
screen is in big trouble on a three it's
not not clear to me how to catch it if
he does totally nothing moved let's
shake and am I not catching the Queen
like this this is what I was thinking
yes like this huh I night see form and
he only loses a piece now this this
wasn't the best then definitely it keeps
a while plus 1 yeah it's nice but it's
not not a killer and well I'm glad to
have won this game thanks for watching